whilst today marks the end of this
inquest it will never mark the end of
the pain for all of our families and
loved ones
nothing will ever been bring back Sophie
Lee Stephen or Kate
on the 12th of August 2021 our lives
were changed forever
our hearts are still incredibly heavy
with grief
and we are struggling to come to terms
with our loss
we will never be able to understand or
comprehend why Davidson did what he did
it was an act of Pure Evil
however
we now know that this evil at was
facilitated and enabled by a series of
failings and incompetence from the
people and organizations
that are supposed to keep us safe
the system has hopelessly failed us
in particular the Devon and Cornwall
police force has failed us
the evidence we have heard during this
inquest over the past five weeks is a
consistent story of individual failures
breathtaking incompetence
and systemic failings within within
every level of the Firearms licensing
unit of the devil and Cornwall police
it is beyond us how Davidson a man with
a known History of Violence
mental health issues
with no real need to own a firearm was
granted a license to possess a gun in
the first place
Davison then brutally battered to
innocent children in an assault in the
park
Davidson's brutal attack was incorrectly
categorized as a low-level assault
following this attack his firearms
license was revoked and his gun was
seized
despite being charged with violently
assaulting two innocent children
unbelievably he was given his license
and his gun back
Davidson was considered
to be a low risk by the devil and
Cornwall police
the evidence that we have heard from
Devon and police
was that of a system
that was a shambles from the top to the
bottom